Have you ever wondered why the word Ambulance
is printed as its mirror image on the front
an Ambulance truck? The word is written this
way so that drivers can read the word in their
rearview mirror signaling them to pull over
if necessary. In chemistry and biology, molecules
can also be mirror image of each other and
have very different functions.
This video is part of the Structure-Function-Properties
video series. The structure, function and
properties of a system are related and depend
on the processes that define or create the
system.
Hi, my name is Brad Pentelute, and I am a
professor of chemistry at MIT. My research
focuses on the biological properties of mirror-image
proteins and how these macromolecules may
be used in pharmaceutical applications and
therapeutics.
Before watching this video, you should be
familiar with: Molecular Geometry, the structure
of the 20 naturally occurring amino acids,
as well as have an understanding of what a
protein is and its three-dimensional structure
After watching this video, you will be able
to:
Identify chiral objects and molecules
Understand how chirality plays a role in the
function of biological compounds.
Let's begin by talking about chirality. In
this video, you'll see that chirality is an
important feature in biological molecules
because molecular structure is often closely
related to biological function.
A molecule is chiral if it is not superimposable
with its mirror image. But, before we talk
about chirality in molecules, let's first
look at a couple of ordinary objects to learn
exactly what we mean by the term, chirality.
Let's look at a common example of chirality
in this left and right glove. Gloves are mirror
images of one another. The gloves look identical
but we know from experience that they are
not the same. They have different shapes.
One fits only your left hand and the other
fits only your right hand. If we try to lay
the right glove on top of the left glove and
align their key features, we see that they
are not superimposable at all. Because left
and right gloves are non-superimposable mirror
images, we can say that gloves are chiral.
Are there other objects that you can think
of that are chiral? Please pause the video
here to think of a few examples.
You may have suggested such objects as your
left or right ears, a drinking fountain, or
a screw.
Let's look at this airplane. Is it chiral?
If we take the airplane and compare it to
its mirror image, we can see that the two
images are identical and are superimposable.
Therefore, the airplane is not chiral. Can
you describe what characteristic of the airplane
makes it achiral? Please pause the video and
give a possible answer.
There is a plane of symmetry through the center
of the airplane itself. If one half of an
object can be reflected onto its other half,
then the object is never chiral. Can you think
of another object with an internal plane of
symmetry? Please pause the video and try to
think of other achiral objects and where the
internal plane of symmetry would be.
Objects such as a chair, a drinking glass,
and a fork have an internal plane of symmetry
and hence are achiral. The planes of symmetry
are here, here, and here.
Notice that there is no way to divide a right-handed
glove into two equal halves, which is why
the glove is chiral.
Finally, another everyday object that I want
to show you is this fan. First, let's think.
Do you think a fan is chiral? Please pause
the video and discuss this with a friend.
Is the fan chiral? Yes, it is. Each blade
is hung with a tilt that makes the fan chiral!
The function of the tilted blades pushes air
forward to create a wind chill effect to cool
you. However, the tilted blades also cause
the fan to be non-superimposable with its
mirror image. As you can see, the mirror image
has blades that tilt in the opposite direction.
All objects can be classified as chiral or
achiral, including molecules.
As with objects, a molecule is chiral if it
is non-superimposable with its mirror image.
The mirror image of a chiral molecule is called
its enantiomer. Enantio is Greek for opposite
and the term enantiomer describes the relationship
between the two molecules.
Enantiomers have identical molecular formulas
and have the same chemical connectivity but
differ in the three-dimensional spatial arrangement
of the atoms in the molecule.
Let's look at this model of the molecule,
bromo-chloro-iodo methane. The green ball
represents a chlorine atom, the orange ball
represents a bromine atom, the purple ball
represents an iodine atom and the white ball
represents a hydrogen atom.
If we take our molecule and hold it in front
of a mirror, we see the molecule and its image
in the mirror. But, now let's look at 3-D
models of both our original molecule and its
mirror image. We see that the two are not
superimposable, regardless of how one rotates
the molecules. Hence, this tells us that bromo-chloro-iodo
methane is a chiral molecule.
A quick way to know if a molecule is chiral
is to check and see if it has a chiral center.
A chiral center is a tetrahedral atom attached
to four different atoms or groups. The tetrahedral
atom is usually carbon.
Let's make a model of the organic compound,
2-chlorobutane. The number 2 in front of the
compound name means that chlorine is on the
second carbon atom. This carbon is attached
to four different groups, chlorine, hydrogen,
a -CH3 group and a -CH2CH3 group and that
means that it's a chiral center.
What would happen to the chirality of this
compound if we substituted the hydrogen atom
with a second chlorine atom? Would the resulting
molecule be chiral? Please pause the video
here.
This new molecule, called 2, 2 di-chlorobutane
is not chiral. The second carbon with two
chlorine atoms no longer has four different
groups attached. You can even see that this
molecule has an internal plane of symmetry
and therefore can be superimposable on its
mirror image.
When we do have a chiral molecule, sometimes
its enantiomer has an entirely different function.
For example, the enantiomers of Carvone are
the flavors of caraway and spearmint. One
enantiomer of Carvone fits into a specific
receptor in your nose only in the way a left-handed
glove fits your left hand. The other enantiomer
of carvone fits into an entirely different
receptor, resulting in the different odor.Many
drugs such as the pain reliever, ibuprofen
has biological activity while its enantiomer
As with simple molecules, it is possible for
proteins to exist that are mirror images of
each other. However, this doesn't occur in
nature. Naturally occurring proteins are composed
of L-amino acids only. It is not clear why
nature selected for this particular enantiomer.
Selection of L-amino acids has structural
consequences for a proteins three-dimensional
shape.
Pause the video here and discuss with a friend
the general structure of amino acids. What
are the groups attached to the central carbon?
Which if any of the amino acids are achiral?
An amino acid contains both an amino group
and a carboxylic acid group. It also contains
a hydrogen atom and a sidechain. The central
atom is carbon. Of the 20 naturally occurring
amino acids, glycine is the only achiral amino
acid. Its sidechain is a second hydrogen atom.
The remaining 19 amino acids have the L configuration.
Let us recall that naturally occurring amino
acids have an L-configuration and combine
to form L-proteins. However, scientists can
now chemically synthesize proteins made up
entirely of D-amino acids. These synthetic
macromolecules are also known as D-proteins.
Interestingly, these proteins fold into three-
dimensional structures, which mirror those
of the naturally occurring L-protein counter-part.
Snow fleas are a species of dark blue insect.
They are often seen bouncing around on the
snow in the winter. Ice fish live in the Antarctic.
These fish live in the ocean at subzero temperatures.
What do the snow flea and the arctic fish
have in common? They can both survive in subfreezing
temperatures. How do they do this? Both creatures
make a class of proteins called Antifreeze
proteins. These proteins protect these organisms
and others, including moths, beetles, plants
and even bacteria by binding to water and
stopping the growth of ice crystals in their
bodies.
Is water chiral? Please pause the video here
and try to answer this question.
Here you can see the chemical structure of
water. As you can see, it has two planes of
symmetry, and water is superimposable with
its own mirror image.
The antifreeze protein is comprised of 81
amino acids folded into six helices. Each
helix is connected by amino acids that form
a short connecting loop. The helices in the
antifreeze protein are left-handed. Do you
think the helices are chiral? Pause the video
and discuss this with a friend.
The helix winds up in the direction of your
left thumb when your fingers are curled in
to make a fist. These helices do not have
an internal plane of symmetry, and are not
superimposable with their mirror images. They
are chiral.
The antifreeze protein was the first protein
whose mirror image was chemically synthesized.
The mirror image protein is composed of entirely
D-amino acids. The helices are right-handed,
opposite to that of the naturally occurring
protein. They wind up in the direction of
your right thumb when your fingers are curled
in to make a fist. In proteins, we see chirality
in the amino acid units and in the secondary
structure as well.
Do you think the D-form of the antifreeze
protein will have a function the same as or
different from the natural L-form? Please
pause the video here and discuss with a friend.
Interestingly, the mirror image protein has
the same antifreeze properties. This is because
its binding partner, water is achiral. So
the mirror image protein can still bind water.
Hopefully by now you have the tools to recognize
chiral objects and molecules, and the role
that chirality can play in recognition and
specificity between biological systems. In
this video, we saw that an object or molecule
is chiral if it cannot be superimposed onto
its mirror image. Objects or molecules that
have an internal plane of symmetry are never
chiral. We also talked about enantiomers,
which are the mirror image of a chiral molecule.
Since the spatial orientation of the atoms
in enantiomers are different, chiral compounds
can and often do have distinct functions.
But, as you saw with the antifreeze protein,
sometimes there are exceptions to the rule!